After eight installments and countless action
sequences, the Fast and Furious franchise
has its first spinoff in Hobbs & Shaw.
Now that we've seen everything this movie
has to offer, we're here to give you the lowdown
on the best, and worst, things in this chapter
of the saga.
Every installment of the Fast & Furious franchise
has gotten bigger, wilder, and more action-packed
than the ones before it.
For everyone worried that the absence of Vin
Diesel's Dominic Toretto and his "family"
would lead to a lull in the action, Hobbs
& Shaw keeps the fists flying and the cars
racing.
Every single major set piece in the film feels
bigger than the last, as Hobbs and Shaw punch,
kick, and bicker their way across the globe.
Anyone familiar with director David Leitch's
cinematic output could have expected that
the former stuntman would put together all
sorts of over-the-top action sequences, but
the co-director of John Wick easily surpasses
all expectations.
There's a palpable sense of glee at the heart
of Hobbs & Shaw, as if Leitch and his team
can't believe they get to create some of the
wacky stunts they're paid to make.
There are cameos aplenty in Hobbs & Shaw:
WWE wrestler, and Dwayne Johnson's real-life
cousin, Roman Reigns appears as one of the
Hobbs brothers.
Kevin Hart, appearing on screen once again
with his former Central Intelligence co-star
Johnson, appears in the film as Dinkley, an
over-eager air marshal.
Catastrophe and Deadpool 2 star Rob Delaney
appears as agent Loeb.
Leitch even manages to use his pull as the
director of Deadpool 2 to bring in Ryan Reynolds
as agent Locke.
While it's a delight to see so many talented
comedic actors, and their appearances provide
some of the funniest parts of the film, unfortunately
they also slow the pacing down to a crawl.
Many of the scenes they appear in drag on
way too long, and seemingly exist in the final
cut just to showcase the A-list talent that
the film attracted.
As funny as Hart, Reynolds, and Delaney are,
their appearances distract from the film more
than they benefit it.
While some of the cameos in Hobbs & Shaw drag
on a touch too long, Dame Helen Mirren's appearance
as Queenie Shaw feels far, far too short.
It's a source of near constant delight that
Mirren, one of the greatest and most venerated
actresses working today, has decided to spend
her time as a trash-talking criminal in the
Fast & Furious franchise.
In Hobbs & Shaw, Queenie is incarcerated for
unknown reasons, visited occasionally by her
son, and biding her time until she feels like
breaking out.
The credits scene implies a prison break for
the Shaw matriarch, so there's plenty of room
to hope that Mirren will continue to delight
in whatever future installments she appears
in.
Vanessa Kirby, who plays Hattie Shaw, is 31
years old.
Hattie's brother in the film, Deckard, is
played by Jason Statham, who is 52.
Throughout the film, we see flashbacks to
the two of them as con artist kids, and they
look to be about the same age…so how old
is Hattie Shaw supposed to be?
It's a fairly consistent aspect of action
movies to have a massive difference in age
between the male and female co-stars, but
it's distracting to have Hobbs & Shaw position
Kirby as more or less the same age as Statham
and Johnson.
There's even an ongoing flirtation between
Hattie and Hobbs that ultimately leads to
a kiss between the two, and Dwayne Johnson
is 47.
"My kind of girl!"
"I see what you're doing.
Do you think I'm stupid?"
"Of course I think you're stupid."
Is Kirby playing a character at least a decade
older than her actual age?
Or is Hattie in her early 30s, too?
Does it even matter?
After all, Kirby also smooched 57-year-old
Tom Cruise in Mission Impossible: Fallout,
so her Hobbs & Shaw casting might be just
to set up another stereotypical May-December
action movie romance.
Hobbs & Shaw takes plenty of opportunities
to showcase the two muscular men at odds and
working together, and it's a delight nearly
the entire time.
Whether it's showcasing how the two go about
their very different days in a color-coded
split-screen or seeing them kick butt together,
their odd couple chemistry is a hoot.
It's also an aspect of the Fast & Furious
franchise that has been missing for a while.
2 Fast 2 Furious briefly presents Paul Walker
and Tyrese Gibson as conflicted, equally tough
partners, but that scenario barely lasts for
the length of the film before Walker's character
Brian clearly becomes the leader.
Furthermore, Brian and Dom's brotherly rivalry
in subsequent movies never really has the
serious energy that you need to get invested
in who's the faster or more furious of the
two.
However, Hobbs and Shaw spend the whole movie
trading barbs, punches, and dirty looks.
When they finally team up for the climactic
fight, it feels earned and satisfying.
While the film stays pretty thematically true
to the past few iterations of the Fast & Furious
franchise, Hobbs & Shaw still feels removed
from the main run of films.
Besides a quick line of dialogue referencing
Kurt Russell's Mr. Nobody and some use of
nitrous in the climax, the filmmakers don't
really seem interested in making Hobbs & Shaw
much of a Fast & Furious film.
In a vacuum, that's perfectly reasonable.
Leitch has said that there's plenty of room
for sequels here, and keeping the focus on
the two leading men and mostly new characters
is a good way to keep that potential open.
Still, in terms of feeling like the same universe
and the same characters we've seen before,
Hobbs & Shaw could easily be an entirely different
film outside of the Fast & Furious franchise.
With Dwayne Johnson and Vin Diesel reportedly
at each other's throats on the set of Fate
of the Furious, and Hobbs & Shaw seeming more
and more like a way to keep Johnson involved
in the franchise without stepping on Diesel's
toes, the film's uneven tone and relationship
to its parent franchise feels even stranger.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
action franchises are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.